pleinement signe un mot sur l'actualité
à la sphère benallal etc semblent hélas
on garde à vue depuis hier matin
toujours en garde à vue à l'heure où on
se parle il sera auditionné lundi par la
commission denquête ici au sénat qu'est
ce que vous attendez de cette audition
faisons déjà qu elle chancelle sénat
parce que vous avez remarqué que quand
on a une majorité en marche on n'a plus
droit de commissionnement qui est
l'assemblée on dit privé j'en attends de
toujours ce qu'est ce qu'elle arrive à
faire parce qu'on voit les
contradictions éclaté depuis maintenant
des semaines on est un personnage
alors soit disant l'elysée a réclamé les
deux passeports diplomatiques
alors maintenant s'il met compris après
une technique entre les lits le le
ministère de l'intérieur ministère des
affaires étrangères qui explique que les
passeports aient pas été restreint tout
ça est encore trop de cambo l'aise et en
réalité en qualité on sent bien que pour
arriver à faire le clair sur cette
affaire d'état parce que c'est une
affaire d'état d'accord où on a à
pouvoir qui au fur et à mesure à donner
des réponses en recul au toujours on
recule on vous rappelle qu'au début
c'était un organisateur de voyages cet
été benallal on s'est aperçu qu'il avait
un rôle majeur dans la sécurité de
l'elysée alors qu'il n'y en a aucune des
complets des prérogatives officiel et
maintenant on s'aperçoit que bon
manifestement il entretient des rapports
avec l'afrique qui laisse à penser qu'il
est plus sûr
un rapport de la politique france
afrique de l'élysée plutôt que d'aider
des simples aux intérêts privés en tout
cas on aimerait ça le voir moi j'allais
dire qu'il faudrait maintenant
auditionné le chef de l'état enfin je
veux dire il ya tellement d'
incohérences que c'est ça qu'il faudrait
faire pour connaître la vérité j'espère
que le sénat va le réclamer d'ailleurs
même si je sais que le chef de l'état
n'est pas obligé de venir ils pourraient
venir de son propre chef
clarifier cette situation donc vous
demander ma foi je vous rappelle qu'en
novembre il expliqué aux journalistes
qu'il fallait avoir de la mansuétude
vis-à-vis de monsieur benalla enfin
monsieur vidal est un faussaire de génie
et quelque part j'allais dire un espèce
de belphégor de l'elysée qui hantait
l'elysée arrivé à à manipuler les choses
soit il était saoul services de de
monsieur monsieur macro et là c'est
inquiétant parce que c'est la start up
nation qui organise la sécurité y
compris de manière violente qui organise
les rapports françafrique et c'est
totalement en dehors de l'état de droit
et donc en chef la troisième hypothèse
ben tout nous laisse penser en tout cas
qu'elle est possible je fais attention
mais tout nous laisse penser qu'elle est
possible et suffisamment d'éléments
donc il faudrait pouvoir aller plus loin
que d'interroger monsieur belaala ou
directeur de cabinet de l'elysée